tenemos por aquí dos aminoácidos podemos
ver los signos que nos indican que esto
en efecto es un aminoácido tenemos por
aquí un grupo amino que aporta la parte
de camino en el nombre de aminoácido y
tenemos un grupo car box y lo por acá
que es la parte ácida del aminoácido y
aquí en medio tenemos un carbono al que
le llamamos el carbono alfa ok le
llamamos a este el carbono alfa y el
carbono alfa va a estar enlazado con un
hidrógeno y con alguna cadena lateral a
esta le llamamos la cadena r 1 y en este
aminoácido le llamamos la cadena r 2 y
en lo que nos vamos a enfocar en este
vídeo es cómo podemos tomar dos
aminoácidos y con ellos formar un
péptido y solo como un recordatorio un
péptido
el vestido es simplemente una cadena de
aminoácidos ok es una cadena de
aminoácidos así es que cómo le hacemos
para tomar dos aminoácidos y formar un
péptido en este caso estamos formando un
divertido que es una cadena de dos
aminoácidos y los divertidos son los más
pequeños de los péptidos pero después
podemos seguir agregando por aquí otros
aminoácidos y entonces obtendríamos un
polipéptido y una forma muy general de
observar esta reacción es decir que el
nitrógeno usa este par de electrones
libres para formar un enlace covalente
con este carbono del grupo carbón y lo
entonces este nitrógeno llega y forma un
enlace con este carbono del grupo carbon
hilo y luego este hidrógeno y este
oxígeno y este otro hidrógeno se pueden
utilizar para formar una molécula de
agua que hay para formar una molécula de
a que estos dos aminoácidos están
dejando ir así es que en esta reacción
terminamos con que el nitrógeno tiene un
enlace covalente con este carbono y
además liberamos una molécula de agua y
justo porque estamos liberando esta
molécula de agua al igual que como hemos
visto en muchas otras reacciones justo
como se está liberando esta molécula de
agua decimos que es una reacción de
condensación o una síntesis por
deshidratación reacción de condensación
o también conocida como síntesis por
deshidratación y vimos justo este tipo
de reacción cuando estábamos juntando
glucosas cuando estábamos formando
carbohidratos ok síntesis por
deshidratación y bueno yo siempre que
veo una reacción de estas me gusta poder
contar las cosas y decir ok está todo
muy bien esto se va a enlazar con esto
podemos ver el enlace por aquí y voy a
soltar esto y esto que en total es h2o
una molécula de agua pero como podemos
imaginarnos que sucede todo esto podemos
empujar estos electrones así de esta
forma porque no hacemos un poquito de
química orgánica avanzada para ver qué
es lo que está pasando en el fondo por
aquí y eso es justo lo que vamos a hacer
ahorita no vamos a llegar a ver un
mecanismo de reacción formal pero sí
vamos a tener una muy buena idea de qué
es lo que está pasando
empezamos por aquí el nitrógeno tiene
este par de electrones libres el
nitrógeno es muy
negativo y por otro lado tenemos aquí
este carbono que está enlazado con 2
oxígenos los oxígenos son más electro
negativos que los carbonos así es que
estos oxígenos están abrazando a todos
estos electrones por lo que este
nitrógeno tal vez quiera hacer algo que
en química orgánica nos referimos como
ataque el núcleo físico sobre este
carbono de aquí y cuando hace eso si
estuviéramos haciendo un mecanismo de
reacción más formal tal vez en este
momento diríamos que uno de estos
enlaces del doble enlace los electrones
de ese enlace van y se quedan con el
oxígeno en el momento en que sucede esto
y entonces el oxígeno tendría una carga
negativa pero luego ese par de
electrones libres puede regresar con el
carbono y se vuelve a formar el enlace
doble y mientras sucede eso este oxígeno
de este grupo hidroxilo se va a quedar
con estos electrones del enlace
ok este oxígeno se va a quedar con estos
electrones de este enlace y entonces
ahora tiene un par de electrones libres
extra
ok vamos a borrar este enlace este
oxígeno ya tenía dos pares de electrones
libres pero como se quedó con los
electrones de este enlace ahora tiene
otro par de electrones libres y por lo
tanto tiene una carga negativa y como te
puedes imaginar va a llevarse algún
protón de hidrógeno en algún momento y
por supuesto que se puede llevar
cualquier protón de hidrógeno de la
solución pero el hidrógeno más
conveniente es este de aquí porque como
este nitrógeno va a usar este par de
electrones libres para formar un enlace
con este carbono entonces va a tener una
carga positiva así es que seguramente se
va a querer quedar con estos electrones
de aquí por lo que fácilmente nos
podemos imaginar a este oxígeno
utilizando uno de sus pares de
electrones libres para quedarse con el
protón de hidrógeno de aquí y entonces
el nitrógeno se puede
con estos electrones del enlace bueno
espero que no te haya parecido demasiado
complicado todo lo que hicimos por aquí
y a mí la verdad siempre me encanta
pensar en qué es lo que está pasando por
aquí podemos ver por aquí que este par
de electrones libres del nitrógeno forma
un enlace con este carbono forma este
enlace naranja de aquí ya este tipo de
enlace le llamamos enlace peptídicos
enlace pep típico y también tenemos la
liberación de una molécula de agua
tenemos este oxígeno que es este oxígeno
y nos podemos imaginar que este
hidrógeno es este hidrógeno de aquí y
este este de acá y entonces ya funciona
muy bien todo y bueno la primera vez que
vi a esta reacción me pareció que poco
tenía mucho sentido que todo estaba
perfecto excepto por el detalle de que
si hablamos de niveles de ph
fisiológicos los aminoácidos se ven más
bien de esta forma
en el rango de niveles fisiológicos de
ph lo más probable es que nos
encontremos a los aminoácidos de esta
forma como 'twitter' iones y déjame
escribo esa palabra por aquí suena como
una palabra muy divertida sweater y es
una sola palabra pero la voy a escribir
con dos colores diferentes para
identificar cada una de sus partes como
podemos ver es un sweater jon y que es
lo que eso significa bueno pues la parte
de twitter en alemán significa híbrido
así es que estamos hablando de un millón
híbrido nuclear y es unión que tiene
distintas cargas en los extremos de la
molécula partes de la molécula tienen
una carga pero cuando juntamos todas las
cargas la molécula en total es neutra
así es que en condiciones fisiológicas
el grupo amino éste nitrógeno de aquí en
un extremo del aminoácido el nitrógeno
suele tener un protón extra y por lo
tanto una carga positiva y por
lado el grupo car box y lo suele perder
uno de sus protones y tiene una carga
negativa y bueno esto que tenemos aquí
de hecho está en equilibrio con lo que
teníamos antes pero a niveles
fisiológicos de ph los aminoácidos
suelen tomar esta forma de su interior y
entonces ahora sí como le hacemos para
pasar de esta forma a un enlace
peptídicos bueno como nos podemos
imaginar aquí este oxígeno acaba de
quedarse con un par extra de electrones
libres porque dejó que se fuera el
protón de hidrógeno ok entonces el
oxígeno tenía originalmente dos pares de
electrones libres pero ahora tiene un
par de electrones libres más que estamos
dibujando de morado y bueno tal vez
puede llegar y usar este par de
electrones libres para quedarse con
algún protón que esté flotando por la
solución o tal vez sólo para que las
cuentas salgan más fácil puede ser que
este oxígeno choque de la forma
con este hidrógeno de aquí se queda con
este protón y permite que el nitrógeno
se quede con estos electrones de aquí y
si llegara a suceder esto entonces al
menos este grupo car box y lo y este
grupo amino regresarían a tener la forma
que estábamos viendo hace unos cuantos
minutos aquí este oxígeno tendría un
hidrógeno y entonces formaría un grupo
hidroxilo y si el nitrógeno recupera
este par de electrones entonces va a ser
otra vez
nh 2 un grupo amino normal y por lo
menos estas partes de las moléculas se
van a ver como las teníamos por acá así
es que nos podemos imaginar fácilmente
como volvemos a obtener este enlace
peptídicos
obtenemos este enlace específico y ahora
la única diferencia entre el péptido que
obtenemos aquí y el anterior es que este
péptido de aquí también es un sweater
jon es un de péptido en su forma de su
interior
este grupo car box y lo de aquí se
mantiene habiendo donado uno de sus
protones y por acá este nitrógeno del
grupo amino sigue teniendo un protón
demás así es que seguimos teniendo una
carga neta neutra a pesar de que tenemos
cargas en ambos extremos en fin espero
que te haya agradado este vídeo